ça me choque j'ai vu cette cette
déclaration du président du cfcm nous
l'auditionner d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
à l'assemblée nationale dans une mission
qui a créé le groupe l'est républicain
la demande de damien abad et je
copréside avec annie genevard eric diard
7 cette mission donc à 12 heures nous
avons monsieur moussaoui devant nous je
lui dirai moi je suis extrêmement choqué
on eu des gossip pas avec nos principes
fondamentaux
c'est pas la république de s'adapter à
telle ou telle religion
les religions sont soumises comme et
c'est ce qu'ils croient des religions et
je les respecte
quel que soit le culte naturellement
sont soumises aux lois de la république
et 7
ce discours est extraordinairement
préoccupant voilà on est dans france en
france dans le pays des lumières dans un
pays de liberté on a le droit de
caricaturer on a le droit au blasphème
ça fait partie de nos valeurs chacun
exprime avec de la façon qu'ils
souhaitent
mais remettre ses libertés en cause par
rapport à des principes religieux
ça veut dire qu'une loi religieuse
serait supérieure aux lois de la
république et pour moi c'est n'est
absolument jamais jamais consommables ce
don
[Musique]